nobody knows of queen america's true
intentions nobody is meant to that's the
entire story of eldon ring in my opinion
it's all up to the interpretation of the
player we may never know the exact
answers for anything along any timeline
but that's okay honestly it's more fun
to interpret than look for straight
facts there are obviously specifics
within the game that are of course
factual but when it comes to the main
theme of elden ring i believe that's up
to the player and what i see as the main
theme of elden ring is all centered
around queen america who gave the lands
between all the pieces of the puzzle to
do with as they wish and make a change
in the world today we're going to talk
about queen america's involvement with
melina the round table hold and how they
might not actually exist but are only
meant to influence your decisions and
strength as a tarnished before we
continue i'd like to talk about our
sponsor for today's video one of the
highest rated mmos of all time guild
wars 2 which just launched on steam for
the first time ever their latest
expansion end of dragons is out now that
adds to over 200 hours of gameplay for
you to experience a healthy diverse
inclusive community a robust character
creator and some of the most dynamic
mounts seen in current mmos all
completely for free no subscription
required check out the link in the
description to get an xp boost pack and
a mini pet for your new guild wars 2
character the bundle also includes an
item karma an experience booster a 10
slot bag and a black lion miniature all
a 10 value yours to redeem today to
redeem it click the link in the
description it'll take you to the
igames.gg website and it will give you a
detailed breakdown on how you can redeem
these items go check it out today and
thank you guild wars 2 for sponsoring
this video
in america's own words
the urgery governs all
the choice is thine
become one with the order
or divest thyself of it
to wallow at the fringes
a powerless upstart
hear me
demigods
my children beloved make of thyselves
that which he desire
be as a lord be it a god
but should he fail to become ought at
all
he will be forsaken
amounting only to sacrifices
i believe this was america's way of
warning her children and potentially
everyone through the lands between that
the golden order will take them and use
them if they don't make something of
themselves the golden order used godfrey
and his warriors to defeat all who
oppose them and after they had defeated
all of their enemies america knew that
the greater will would no longer need
them so instead of letting the golden
order use them for sacrifices america
took away their guidance of grace and
banish them from the lands between not
because they were now unneeded but to
protect them to send them away to live
and die in the glory of battle to become
the tarnished for the new coming age
my lord and thy warriors i divest each
of thee
of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed ye will be driven
from the lands between he will wage war
in a land afar where you will live and
die
in our video this theory changes
everything we discuss america's grand
scheme to make sure the golden order
would either be destroyed replaced or
affected in some way by us as the
tarnished after queen america shatters
the elden ring america knew that the
golden order would need the tarnish to
return to the lands between and fix what
was broken she banished godfrey's
warriors so that they wouldn't have to
become sacrifices to the golden order
but would instead be used to finish off
what she started the greater will
expected the tarnish to just mend its
order back together but what they didn't
expect was for us to have minds of our
own and make our own choices based on
our journey toward the elven ring we
meet all kinds of characters throughout
the game all having different
aspirations and goals america gave us
this option to choose and made sure that
no matter what we do choose at the end
the golden order would never be the same
again this is where i believe the round
table hold comes into play it is
described as a hub area that exists
outside the lands between a place to
mingle with our adventurers craftsmen
resupply and discover a trove of
blessings and rooms of secrets but as
most of us know the round table does
exist in the lands between an almost
identical layout can be found in the
capital city which suggests that the
round table we enter was influenced off
of this area i believe the round table
hold is just a manifestation by queen
america as a central hub for us
tarnished to become stronger i say this
because i also believe melina is just a
manifested fragment of queen america
this is all suggested by her ability to
recite words from queen america at
certain sites of grace her ability to
use shattered runes we collect from the
elden ring to make the tarnish stronger
her ability to transport us to the round
table hold for her to be used as
kindling to burn down the urgery her
literally telling us that her mother
resides inside the herd tree yet she
doesn't know what it's like to have a
mother and even her pink hair which
could potentially be a mix of america
and ratagon
i was born
at the foot of the earth tree where
mother gave me my purpose
though now
everything is lost to me i
have to ascertain for myself
the reason for which i live
burned
and bodiless
your seamster
bock i see him crying from time to time
i think he misses his mother
he wants someone to tell him he's
beautiful
does being born of a mother
mean one behaves in such a manner
speaking of inside the earth tree it's
been theorized that the round table hold
resides somewhere inside the archery
because once we kindle the forge and
start the burning process of the tree
the round table starts to burn as well
however we also know that queen america
is trapped inside the erd tree clearly
being punished for the shattering of the
elden ring we can learn more from enya
and the two fingers inside the round
table hold who are likely the fingers
and finger maiden of queen america
herself queen marika is the vessel of
the elden ring carrier of its vision
a god in truth
but after the elton rings shattering
she was imprisoned
in the earth tree
a grim punishment for shattering the
order
despite her godhood
but just as we talked about melano was
born inside the earth tree and is
potentially a manifested fragment of
queen america the reason the round table
is burning may not only be because of
the archery but because melania was used
as kindling we aren't entirely sure how
this kindling process works if it even
means melano is fully burned and dies in
the process we never see her again but
it doesn't mean she's completely gone it
just means that she is now burned and
bodyless the reason for which i live
burned
and bodiless now you may be asking
yourself what about melano being the
glomide queen how does destin death play
into all of this the definition of a
manifestation is an event action or
object that clearly shows or embodies
something especially a theory or an
abstract idea it's important to
understand that if melano is a
manifestation created by queen america
it means that melano was created by the
embodiment of something or someone that
america was already aware of it's just
like the round table hold right an
embodiment of this area in the capital
city it was something america and
therefore melana was aware of knew of
and could create a manifestation off of
it america was the one who ordered
malakath to take away the rune of death
from the glomide queen but as we know a
fragment of that rune was stolen from
malakath and used in the night of black
knives to be infused with the assassin's
daggers to kill godwin's soul in
ronnie's body thou
who approacheth
destined death
i will not have it stolen
from me again
what i'm suggesting here is that america
manifested melana from the embodiment of
the glomide queen and the stolen
fragment of the rune of death i've
always found it interesting that if we
release dust and death fully and obtain
the power of the flame of frenzy this is
the only way we can see melina become
the glomide queen either her full
embodiment of the glomide queen was
released after we defeat malakath and
release destin death or the glomide
queen was trapped hidden away or
otherwise unneeded until we do choose to
become the lord of chaos my theory is
that this tattoo that we can see on
melania's left eye is a marking placed
here by malaketh when he defeated the
glomide queen to seal away her true
power we can see in the flame of frenzy
ending that her closed eye when opened
is a gloam color that has many
similarities to the beast eye which
reads as a claw marked stone eye i
believe understanding what was once real
but is now a manifestation when we play
the game can help us understand the
timeline of events in elden ring much
better which is already difficult enough
it can help us understand intentions
from characters that may have not made
sense to us otherwise the manifestation
of the round table hold by queen america
was meant to help us on our journey
through the lands between to help us
reach our goal and meet with all of
these different characters to mold us
into the tarnished that we choose to be
here we can learn about pretty much
everything the doubtfulness of faith in
the golden order the lives of those who
live in death and how they are treated
by others america's relationship with
the greater will how most of the
tarnished are used and the abilities
that they can truly have how close
relationships can mean everything to
someone and nothing to another how the
harsh world can cause someone to break
completely from any humanity they may
have had left how knowledge is powerful
until you know too much and to forge you
a weapon capable of slaying a god
oh
your divinity have mercy and brought me
forgiveness
the road is yet long a god is not easily
failed
but one day without fail you will have
your wish
so please grant me forgiveness queen
america
the leader of the round table hold is
sir gideon off near who we have
discussed at length in a couple of
different videos i recommend you go
watch these if you have the time but to
put it short gideon is using us to get
what he wants he's watching us
throughout our journey and constantly
gathering knowledge to truly become the
all-knowing for which he calls himself
he doesn't want to do the daunting tasks
of killing all of the demigods to gain
access to the urgery but he does want to
become elden lord we give him
information and as we progress he gives
us information it seems like a pretty
simple exchange but in hindsight we were
just used by him we obtain what he needs
and he tries to steal them from us when
we get close enough to our end goal of
becoming the elden lord ah
i knew you'd come
to stand before the elden ring
to become elden lord
what a sad state of affairs
i commend your spirit but alas
none shall take the throne
queen america has high hopes for us
that we continue to struggle
unto eternity
i believe in this moment that gideon
finally realized what merica was up to
and her overarching plan to destroy
replace or change the golden order and
the greater will being a self-proclaimed
all-knowing being like gideon he's
likely going to get lost in all of this
knowledge and he came to the conclusion
that it would be impossible for a
tarnish to kill a god i know
in my
bones
a tarnished
cannot become
a lord
not even you
a man
cannot
kill
a god
to me this suggests that gideon was
scared of what would happen if we did
reach our goal gideon knows that
obtaining knowledge is unending but he
doesn't know what will happen if the
tarnished reach their goal he doesn't
know if they'll just go back to their
resting spots to once again die as
somebody with no renown the pursuit of
knowledge is without end
the knowledge is never a thing complete
thus i maintain the mantle of all
knowing
perhaps the same could be said of
guidance
who's to say whether we'll remain who we
are
once the fight is finished
what do you think
as one who aspires to become elden lord
gideon seeks knowledge but if the
greater will no longer needs him to
become elden lord then he'll no longer
be able to seek that knowledge he will
no longer be what he sees himself as so
he tries to stop us in a final selfish
act unknowing that this is exactly what
queen america wants he wants a tarnished
that is willing to listen and pay
attention to their surroundings who
witness the corruption that plagues the
lands between and a tarnish that just
won't be blinded by arrogant knowledge
while gideon may have been pursuing all
of the knowledge he possibly could he
failed to see the true meaning behind
all of it he stowed himself away in his
room reading books that give him a vast
variety of knowledge he was annoyed with
the other tarnished even being inside of
his round table i'm sick and tired of
them
these numbi unbe tarnished think us no
more than a shelter from the rain but we
the player talk to the other tarnished
and seek not only knowledge but to
understand why we are truly here and how
it affects everyone in the lands between
this could be why melina chose to help
us although she wasn't entirely sure
we'd be up to the task who knows how
many other tarnished between now and the
shattering that she has chosen who just
didn't live up to the task that was
before them but at least torrent
believed in us from the very start i've
been
testing you
to determine
if the elden ring would truly have you
if you had the metal
to endure this long
and arduous path
it seems my worries were unfounded
torrent had your measure from the very
start
whereas i merely pretended
there is but one other thing i can do to
offer you guidance
i can take you to the round table hold
gathering place
of tarnished champions
guided by grace
the round table hold is not only meant
to make us stronger but it's meant to
introduce us to everything that plagues
this world depending on the type of
person you are the type of player you
are there are many different avenues to
explore here and to eventually make some
world-changing decisions throughout the
lands between
thank you all for watching the video i
really appreciate it make sure to do all
the nice youtube stuff you know like
comment subscribe all if you really want
to we are on our way to 100 000
subscribers i'm really trying to hit
that milestone by the end of the year so
thank you all very much appreciate all
the support thank you again to guild
wars 2 for sponsoring the video make
sure to check out everything about that
in the description and i will see you
all in the next video take care